welcome welcome back to many of you and
I see a few new faces who folks who were
not here yesterday we're here for the
2nd of John Donne's series of Stimson
lectures beyond the democratic maze his
first lecture yesterday was called
diagnosing democracy's power and his
second today understanding democracy's
ascent and then there will be two more
next week same time same place next
month next Tuesday he will talk on
recognizing democracy's disorientation
and then the final lecture our this time
next week on Wednesday recovering our
bearings fatality choice and
comprehension a couple of preparatory
remarks before I turn the podium over to
Professor done as I think I mentioned
yesterday I first came across Dunn's
work in a 1978 book that he wrote called
West and political theory in the face of
the future which had a big impact on me
for for a lot of reasons but something
he said yesterday made me just remember
that a line in that book which even
though I looked for it today to confirm
that I was right and I couldn't find it
with the passage of 33 years and
changing continents and all that I
somehow no longer have it but there was
a there's a line edged into my
consciousness in that book which was
that today we are all Democrats we were
all Democrats today but democratic
theory oscillates between two variants
one dismally ideological and the other
hopelessly utopian and I think that what
he had in mind was the for the dismal
ideological was the sort of
Schumpeterian minimalism that was had
sort of won the day in in real politic
at that time and the hopelessly naive
were the various variants of of ideal
speech theory and so on that were made
King the academic rounds and he had very
interesting things to say about those
subjects but what he did not address is
what he's digging into in these lectures
he didn't address the question why why
is it that democracy has become
ascendant particularly given that it has
these unsatisfying features some other
dimensions of which he took up last time
and I think we're gonna hear more about
today the second thought I had listening
to Professor done yesterday was how
remarkable a lecturer he is he reminds
me of Henry James in that he's able to
to speak in very long but nonetheless
amazingly lucid sentences and it's a
real pleasure to listen to him and so
we're in for another treat I think John
welcome back thank you very much I tried
yesterday to press home a picture of the
singularity and mystery of democracy's
rise to a global ascendancy which
however much it may still be disputed is
unmatched by any previous category in
human political experience I did so
mainly in order to make two points
the first is analytic and causal it's
that that victory has been through out
in essence and in logic a fundamentally
political process a political victory
won by political means and through the
mastering and deployment of political
power in all its multifarious modes and
configurations as with any large-scale
and protracted political process much of
the shape of the victory has issued from
heuristics from the seeking out and
mobilizing of types and sources of force
were previously latent and are
naturalized historians can trace
processes like that in retrospect with
the incomparable privilege of hindsight
but no one can reliably anticipate them
because no one does or can know what is
yet to be discovered you can disagree
indefinitely just by that so and I've no
wish to pretend that the answer is
steadily obvious to me but what you
can't saintly do is deny the
overwhelming lesson of experience that
it simply is so the second point I want
to make is cautionary and also
essentially political and it follows
from the first it's that there's great
political danger in viewing democracy's
current global presence and then as
anything more elevated and predictably
durable than a contingent and
necessarily largely Unseld from parent
political outcome more especially
there's great political hazard in seeing
or sensing within it the reassuring
potency imaginative Ridge arrived but
nonetheless causally efficacious of
something higher purer and safer
descending beneficent li-on politics
from above and soothing and softening
the latter's insistent cruelties and
absurdities as it does so you could say
that that's an idle fears it's no one
and above all no American does or could
see any real political process that way
and certainly as a renegade historian of
ideas I'm not myself aware of any
American who has ever been recorded as
seeing American politics in action in
their own vicinity quite that way at any
time and no one assuredly could think of
it as the illusion of the hour today but
the danger I want to point you and what
to which I'll return in my final lecture
is precisely that
of failing to recognize democracies
global ascendancy as an essentially
political outcome emanating from an
essentially political process no higher
or lower in spiritual valency or
existential security than any other
political process from the allocation of
places on the US Supreme Court or Saudi
Arabian arms contracts congressional
log-rolling
or the adjustment of mafia franchises to
the forging of the Red Cross or Amnesty
International the Society of Jesus or
the KGB I don't of course mean that all
political projects are the same or of
equal value just that every political
process is political in the same way and
that the dramatic variations in
spiritual earlier or material Menace
between them come at least as much from
their ecological settings as from their
specifications of collective goals
it's peculiarly easy for Americans to
miss conceive or fail to apprehend the
political character of democracy's
historical advance over the last three
quarters of a century for two very
different reasons neither in any way
damaging to the United States as a
historical civilization or a political
actor in the first place it's harder for
Americans than it's always been for
those at the receiving end to see
clearly the coercive character of their
own power in use and hard accordingly
for them to distinguish their severely
contingent political winnings from their
just desserts in the second place and
despite the valiant efforts of America's
political scientists for a good century
by now it's hard for them not also to
sentimentalize the category of democracy
itself and do so with the special ease
and lack of inhibition as it passes from
spaces where they
can see for themselves and about which
they know a great deal the larger space
is much further away about which they
know virtually nothing and why exactly
should that be so well I'm afraid I
don't know but one partial answer
perhaps is the extraordinary weight of
imaginative generosity and hope which so
many of America's deepest and most
passionate thinkers have poured into
this category over the last two
centuries barring a handful of
preternaturally sensitive Puritan
ministers no one in North America poured
anything much into the category of
democracy before the middle of the 18th
century an extremely few had occasion
even to mention it but with the
Revolution the forging of the New
Republic and the long usually amorphous
and always disturbingly incomplete
struggle to rectify the anomaly of that
muddled birth and fashioned a decent and
honorable form of shared life for all
components of the people it brought into
existence democracy in due course came
to be not merely the official regime
name for the New Republic but also the
vessel on which generations of America's
most gifted and engaged writers thinkers
and social activists lavished their
aspirations for shared habitat and
Miglia of existence for everyone fated
and entitled to make their lives within
it in America's domestic politics that
great tide of energy and hope has been
pretty effectively blocked for most of
those 200 years and it's not an
adventurous judgment that it's
effectively blocked today unlikely to
remain so for the near future quite deep
domestic frustration and poorly
comprehended external power each exert
disturbing pressure on political
judgment and in combination they make is
especially hard
for an American audience to see
democracy's current political presence
across the world steadily and accurately
what I want to do today is to step
outside that imaginative force field and
look at democracy's global ascent in a
way which detaches it effectively from
local political allegiance or
appropriation the approach I'm going to
follow demands some defense at the
outset since many will see it as a
number already have as necessarily
confused or futile what I'm going to try
to do is to track the passage of the
term democracy across the world and
between languages as it moves out beyond
Europe or its North American diaspora
and to read the political
interpretations it has a vocht in the
course of the dramatically disparate
vicissitudes in which it's figured with
increasing prominence across that ever
widening space I'll do say by necessity
impressionistic Lee and episodically
and no one could mistake the result for
serious intellectual history since that
history still needs to be done country
by country language by language decade
by decade and down by those already
Andes enough with the context in
question to fathom what has occurred
within them I see that huge and barely
initiated collaborative task as just as
urgent politically as it is
intellectually there are very radical
antipathies and profound conflicts of
interest in today's world as there have
been ever since we can see any distance
into human history but I believe those
indubitable sources of danger to each
and every one of us and all that we hold
dear to be dwarfed in scale and acuity
by the towering Menace of our massive
mutual ignorant sand in comprehension we
don't understand the world which we so
precariously share and we don't
understand it in very large
measure because of the pitifully jejune
degree to which we understand one
another or grasp but virtually all the
world's other inhabitants really care
about or why they care about it as they
do if you see that as a fanciful
judgment or a silly press yosity just
turn your minds momentarily to our twin
invasions I speak as a British citizen
addressing an American audience
our twin invasions of Afghanistan and
Iraq and the terrible harms that are
still issuing inexorably from them still
even if you're gracious and patient
enough to take seriously the judgment
that there is a pressing need to
understand the imaginative presence of
those convulsive global encounters
what's the point of seeking to fathom
anything about them by tracing the
vicissitudes of a word there are two
elements to that point one distinctly
more obvious than the other the first
and obvious element is political the
extraordinarily highly protected
political valency of the term in
question the occasion for giving these
lectures at all but the second and less
obvious element is essentially cognitive
or if you like methodological it's the
vastly greater epistemic determinacy of
what you place at the center of the
process you seek to trace the history of
democracy as a word is an exercise in
political philology a severely
underdeveloped intellectual practice
even in the wake of the linguistic turn
and one which in the fullness of time
and pursued with the assiduity it
requires and deserves can and I hope
will in due course draw on some of the
huge cumulative intellectual capital of
the shaping matrix of the Western mind
over almost a millennium and bring that
capital back into active
political views this isn't in any sense
a narrowly Occidental intellectual
project it's just as deep a heritage to
draw on from it has just as deep a
heritage to drawn from the civilizations
of South Asia or of Islam of japan or
korea or above all china in eastern asia
of the handful of scholars across the
world whom i happen to know personally
and know to be aware of the scale and
promise of that task figures like the
columbia sands richest sheldon pollock
or the princeton islamist michael cook
most unsurprisingly
do emanate from or reside in the west
that's unsurprising because that's where
i come from do but there must always
have been and willing the future
assuredly be on a far greater scale
counterparts with at least equal gifts
and justice keen engagement who come
from and remain within all the great
centers of cultural creation and
conservation across the world what human
beings can do in politics depends
principally on the institutional
structures within which they find
themselves sorry with the institutional
structures which confront them and which
are available to them and on the
material environments within which they
find themselves but what they try to do
and even what they choose to attempt
depend every bit as much on how their
imaginations work on how they see and
feel about themselves and about the
human world which surrounds them at
varying distances it's because of its
unmistakably consequential prominence
within that space that we need so
urgently to take in just what has been
happening in and through the passage of
this word across the globe over the last
two centuries what we need to look for
within that passage as i tried to
suggest and yes
his lecture is the horizon of
identification which it's held out to
very many of them and the basis which
it's offered them for discrediting and
denouncing their immediate enemies I
certainly don't want to suggest that
it's invariably enhanced their political
judgment or improved their political
prospects by pressing those
solicitations very often made out its
tantalized them with the promise of a
power control and efficacy which were
largely delusional and led them off
defenseless to the slaughter like some
huge global after echo of the Children's
Crusade or replay of Passchendaele you
might I think bear that point in mind at
that point bear in mind the miseries of
Libya today but however vulnerable that
promise may prove the power to move very
large numbers of human beings is a
formidable political force in itself and
it's hard to overstate the motivating
power of the strictly political services
which this drab little word has seemed
to them to offer to endless millions of
frightened and suffering people or to
exaggerate the scale of the consequence
of its carrying that force to look at
political experience through the
carriage of power by a word is to view
politics from a very odd angle and one
which by itself could scarcely equip
anyone to understand a great deal about
it most people today don't think of
democracy in the first instance as a
word they view it as a form of
government or an assemblage of
institutional practices in this country
less hesitantly than anywhere else in
the world they think of edges of their
form of government and the assemblage of
practices which currently defines that
when they ask about the presence or
absence of democracy elsewhere in the
world what they principally have in mind
is the presence in varyingly distant set
of reasonably good fact similes of that
form of government and of practices
which appear to express more or less
congruous values and commitments to
those which are deemed to inform their
own at least when the latter is on its
best behavior when they go on to inquire
how that form of government has come to
prevail to the degree that it has in
many areas of the world or even why it
initially aroused in their own country
and elements of it or arisen earlier and
elsewhere they look at the formation of
states the techniques of political
control the genesis of resources from
human populations and their mobilization
by rulers or local power holders the
basis on which groups of human beings
can be induced to cooperate or comply
with the requirements pressed on them
from above and those pictures can be
cout detached and comfortably
cosmopolitan they can read history
without disclosing local allegiances
within it or assuming that it carries
legitimate or immoral which favors some
and disfavors others today or tomorrow
approaches like that make it possible to
ask how politics works and doesn't work
and why it takes broadly the forms it
now does without pre committing the
questioner to reaching answers that are
supportive or even comfortable for
anyone at all there are good reasons for
the existence of political sciences and
intellectual genre and a professional
practice but as soon as you ask which of
those forms of government or practices
or presumptive purposes and informing
principles have merit and deserve
Allegiance the hard-won professional
composure of political science is
instantly ruffled and the sense of
coherent inquiry and even if consecutive
good sense soon comes into serious
jeopardy consider the question of
whether it really
was the Greeks who invented democracy
where many contemporary Greek citizens
emphatically wished to affirm a positive
answer and serious and exhaustively
informed students of democracies history
on the other side of the world village
every bit as essential to insist on a
negative one
those who affirm the positive answer
principally wish to claim for their own
a historical experience in some ways
glittering enough in others as ugly as
the historical experiences of every
other human community which happens to
have occurred more or less where they
now live and to have been enacted
principally through a language
intriguingly continuous with their own
that's an innocent enough appropriation
and it's not notably more in genuine
than most communities appropriations of
their own from always fairly discrepant
pasts what irks the creek what irks the
critics of greek claims to be democratic
originators isn't the innocent
narcissism of contemporary Greeks
it's the appropriation of effectively
the same claim on Greece's behalf by the
remainder of Europe and its potent and
wealthy diaspora across the oceans
hence the counterclaim that any
specifiable element of what came to be
called democracy had been prefigured or
pre named in other roughly adjacent
settings especially in continental Asia
before the Greeks came to adopt it it
hasn't so far proved possible to trace
anything very clear or illuminating of
what was or wasn't going on in the
favored settings Mesopotamia Phoenicia
and so on let alone to pin down its
local political significance or
demonstrate that he had definite
consequences for what the best recorded
of Greek communities did to and through
the category of democracy but there's no
reason whatever to dispute the passage
of cultural and intellectual elements
from a wide variety of non Greeks
societies and policies to Greek police
in the epoch in which the term democracy
first came into recorded use or of the
possibility of extensive Greek imitation
experimentation on the basis of earlier
and clearly non Greek practices and
expedience but it's hard to believe in
either case that those are the right
questions to ask
human beings have had to devise ways of
taking and lending authority to binding
collective decisions on the varying
scales on which they've lived together
across the world and for far longer than
we have careful or reliable descriptions
of how they did so it's scarcely
conceivable that there could have been a
distinctive and uniquely compelling
approach to doing so which occurred to
one set of human beings speaking one
language in one place and at one time
but comprehensively failed to occur to
any others elsewhere earlier or later
it's certainly impossible to believe
that the practice of assembling together
to discuss in public what to do didn't
on different scales and bases arise and
persist in every humanly inhabited
continent and do so well before we have
legible records of how its inhabitants
dealt with one another on any scale of
tall and it's merely ludicrous to
imagine that we ourselves have somehow
chanced upon a vision of how to ensure
that when we do assemble together in
person virtually or by proxy to discuss
in public what to do we now have at our
disposal any more regionally compelling
and conception of how that discussion
can be conducted in practice on a basis
which is legitimately disconcerting to
no one what the Greeks did originated
was a word and a word through which
whatever its semantic correlates in
other languages before hand a lot of
dramatic political life occurred within
a wide range of Greek police and most
flamboyantly and our
particularly in athens itself it was
that flamboyance and articular see
whimsically frozen in text which enabled
that word to survive the demise of an
independent Athens and even of the
cities of the eastern and central
Mediterranean which preserved many of
its political forms in outline for many
centuries to come it survived not as an
ideological force or a glaring emblem of
power but as an instrument for thinking
it served for thinking to be sure about
ideological force and about the sources
and modalities of power and the unsteady
relations between power benign political
purposes and beneficial political
consequences but it emphatically didn't
guarantee the benignity or efficacy of
power in use or serve in anyone's eyes
as assurance of the purity of political
purpose nor did it suggest any elective
affinity between the regime form to
which it referred and the successful
pursuit of cognitive validity if
anything the relation it suggested
between this particular regime form and
either political merit or cognitive
insight was more disjunctive than it was
mutually supportive the fact voidage
cheap joke just the fact that the single
most widely dispersed and potent term in
political speech across the world today
and in that sense because of the
relentless growth in the numbers of
living humans the most potent political
term there's ever been
survived in today is into today's world
at all nor as a focus of political
loyalty or a normative aspiration but as
an instrument of thought is as startling
as it is important but that fact of
course does nothing to explain either
why or how it has come to be so widely
dispersed or politically
so potent to grasp those you have to
look at the political history of the
world over the timespan in which it has
spread so widely and picked up such
political momentum you have to watch the
word carefully as it enters the
political repertoire of one country
after another
picking up friends and enemies as it
goes and helping to recompose political
coalition's and reshape political
enmities as it does so look at the world
in 1750 and you can barely see it
present even in heated discussions
between handfuls of politically
motivated intellectuals like Jonathan
Israel's emblematic radical heroes
trudging manfully forwards in the
footsteps of Spinoza look at it as it
leaves the maelstrom of Frances
Revolution and the ravages of Napoleon's
wars of conquest and already it seems to
have hitched its colors to the huge
inchoate movement of egalitarian
reconstruction that shaped so much of
the next century and three-quarters but
which has now been all but extirpated as
an imaginative and energizing political
force whilst that movement called
socialism was still expanding
territorially in however erratic a
manner it fully retained the potential
to set a drastically different frame and
valency on the idea of democracy and to
impose that frame over clumsily and
brutally on the experience of immense
numbers of human beings but in that form
the tide has long ad decisively and all
that's left in the word itself is a
pallid ghost of the power it once held
what has carried that word so far up the
global beach today is to an overwhelming
degree one thing the rail it came to
play in explaining America's politics to
itself
there's still no very illuminating
account of exactly how and why it came
to play that well I think so
Sean Wilentz is American freedom comes
closer on personal than anyone else yet
has but there is as I understand it
reasonably clear agreement amongst
informed scholars that the movement for
American independence and the subsequent
construction of the new republic were in
neither case in any sense political
struggles conducted under the banner of
democracy or intended by almost anyone
James Wilson being probably the most
important exception to establish that
Republic as a regime appropriately
conceived in the round as a democracy in
1776 democracy was simply not a banner
word it was still in close touch with
the cool analytical perspective on
political existence which had launched
it on its lengthy post athenian
historical career and which continued to
confine it to narrowly academic or
intellectual circles for over 2,000
years even within that media it wasn't
viewed as a plausible solution to the
pressing problems for any community of
any scale which recognized itself
willingly or otherwise to face pressing
problems it was simply not the solution
to the riddle of anyone's history within
a more analytical perspective to be sure
it could be employed and sometimes was
employed to refer to properties of the
new American regime by those who hope to
usher it into safe and durable existence
in other contexts some of those
apparently positive observers notably
Alexander Hamilton elsewhere expressed
whether before or afterwards a visceral
hostility to the political arrangements
and turmoil which the word evokes for
them in which they expected you to
arouse in most of their audience
what held the movement for independence
together was a hostility to being
subjected to imperial power and
authority from the other side of the
ocean in a few relatively sophisticated
cases its implications soon came to be
seen as explicitly Republican hostile by
commitment to monarchy as such for John
Adams as early as the spring of 1776
there is no good government but what is
Republican a view he went on in due
course to fill out at a considerable
length but for less decisive and
theoretically relentless participants
democracy was certainly no proxy for a
republic and it was seen as carrying
very specific dangers of its own for
those with very large stakes in the
country simple democracy was close to
pure threat in Maryland in the same year
Charles Carroll of Carrollton one of the
richest men in North America saw the
prospect of the simple democracies he
believed his fellow Constitution makers
intent on establishing as the worst of
all forms of government and bound to end
as all other democracies have in
despotism for James Madison from the
10th Federalist onwards the prospects
for stabilizing and consolidating the
new republic rested not on prevalently
erratic models drawn from a distant
greek past but on the design of a novel
model by a small number of gifted
experienced and dedicated figures with
the political weight and prowess to
carry carry their fellow americans with
them the great body of supporters or
opponents of the new constitution he
insisted must follow the judgment of
others not their own a fortunate
coincidence
of leading opinions and a general
confidence of the people in those who
may recommend it it was that judgment
which lay behind his contributions to
the Federalist
by the fourth decade of the next century
when top fill settled down to work out
and profit of the world his own
incomparable construe the New Republic
had unmistakably embraced democracy in
name as well as in substance once it's a
chosen Republican independence in place
of what it had come to see as Imperial
subjection it had little real
alternative open to it there were rich
families in the ex colonies and there
were plainly as there always have been
social pretensions to go along with
their wealth but by 1776 there was
nothing there which anyone could durably
mistake for an aristocracy and what
dispersed residues of gentility and
condescension remained were manifestly
incapable of setting their stamp upon
the new political order in the end
despite a few early panics none even
made a serious attempt to if
unmistakably a republic and a markedly
are Marist aquatic Republic at that what
was there for their new regime to be but
a democratic republic and a democracy in
due course it newly became both in its
own eyes and until much later when it
met the disapproving gaze of more
belligerently holistic egalitarians in
europe or beyond in the eyes of everyone
else who chose to inspect it you can
disagree as most now do I think with
lewy hearts in seeing that outcome as
imparting a distinctive shallowness to
American political understanding which
in turn reflected its relatively narrow
horizon of social and economic
experience but what you can't really
deny is since his insistence that one of
its principal consequences was to ensure
that the sharpest ideological conflict
over the legitimacy of the new order
came over its compatibility with a
system of unfree labor which required
the laborers in question to be exclude
from citizenship that wasn't an outcome
which would have discomforted
interpreters of democracy in the
communities which first gave referential
meaning to the term but if the War
Between the States had come out
differently it would have had drastic
implications for the global prospects of
America's model of democracy in its
struggle with professed partisans of
equality across most of the rest of the
world whatever it may have felt like to
some of its inhabitants with a fluent
repertoire of denial a slave society
can't readily be seen from the outside
as a system of political equality it's
hard to exaggerate the degree to which
the global ascendancy of democracy as a
category of political aspiration has
come from the competitive appeals of
equality over against those of hierarchy
as a category of political
identification both economic and social
equality have further appeals of their
own and it will always remain an open
question just how far political equality
requires either economic or social
equality to be rendered real and just
how far the challenge of economic
organization precludes the realization
of even the most rudimentary elements of
either economic or social equality
accept a prohibitive cost to see what's
happening to through and around the
category of democracy as it moves from
Europe and North America into other
continents it's necessary to recognize
not merely what governmental forms or
sequences of experience it's taken to
refer to but also what forms of equality
it's heard to threaten or promise and
what types of economic structure are
seen to be compatible with it or
precluded by it everywhere that
democracy now reaches has sooner or
later to learn how to answer those
questions through its own framework of
standing on the basis of its own
political and economic experience and
with its own immediate predicament in
the forefront of its mind the resulting
political process is always
extraordinarily complicated there are
brief passages of specious clarity in
which the problems of mutual
intelligibility apparently drop away and
one regime form collapses with another
and plainly superior briskly replacing
it
the orange revolutions 14 perhaps the
most prominent recent example but it
never takes long for intrinsic that
interpretive complexity to reassert
itself and the fog banks to roll back in
and cut political visibility down to
size since I take none of that cognitive
constriction not as an intellectual
failure on the part of the present
membership of our species or academic
professions a failure that might in
principle be remedied by future
enhancements of our performance but
rather as an ontological feature of the
world given by where and what we are I
see no possibility of moving briskly
beyond it though I certainly hope we may
eventually learn to live to live it with
better grace and mutual forbearance as
an exercise in training such forbearance
it may help to dwell on one or two of
the great historic regime collapses and
reconstructions on other continents
which have reshaped the global structure
of power over the last century for most
of that century would it be natural to
begin with Russia but the indisputable
failure of that notable if clumsily
conducted experiment has rendered the
task of understanding what ensued in it
less urgent without making it any easier
to discharge at least for the present it
seems more urgent to improve our grasp
of what has been going on in the
contrasting adventures of the category
in two other great society
so far confined to Asia as a landmass in
one of these as a part residue of
Britain's Indian Empire the category has
been interpreted primarily in response
to the political conduct and heritage of
the former imperial power though of
course it's been interpreted very
dynamically indeed and I suppose if
admittedly with later and not
overwhelmingly instructive
supplementation from Russia and China
but but in the other in China encounter
with democracy as a practical feature of
the political world from the outset
prompted more attention to America's
idiosyncratic political experience by
great good fortune one of the subtlest
and most illuminating accounts of the
process through which the rest of the
world has had to try to fathom the
promise and menace lurking in this
obtrusively western category is provided
in an article I was lucky enough to have
had pressed on me the last time I was in
Yale for any length of time by your
extraordinarily distinguished historian
of China
Jonathan Spence the article was written
by a Chinese scholar whose name I'm sure
I can't pronounce but spelt Zhang Yu Zhi
summarizing work which he'd undertaken
over several decades it focuses on the
inherent difficulties faced by Chinese
officials scholars and journalists when
they first tried to grasp what American
democracy was and the closely connected
difficulties which foreign missionaries
or journalists also encountered when
they to tried to convey their own
understandings of its practical
character and self interpretation to
Chinese readers or audiences some of
those difficulties were essentially
difficulties of translation in linking
the words of one language elaborated to
understand and operate one set of
political practices in one kind of
Society for those of another language
developed to articulate and enact a very
different set of practices in another
and drastically different kind of
society very broad space to try to cross
in the Chinese case as the most talented
interpreters of China's modern
intellectual history have long
demonstrated with great finesse the
language into which the translation had
to be made was peculiarly ill suited to
registering the point and character of
barbarian political practices because
they should come to be so heavily
impacted on a millennial II reiterated
and consolidated vision of the political
preconditions for civilization itself
the order of the celestial Empire was
implacably hierarchical it privileged
peace and obedience to a single apex of
authority it viewed conflict dissidents
and still more active resistance with
acute suspicion at least until those
responses has receded a tactful distance
into the past and it saw the order which
it promised and aspired to provide as
resting principally on the commitment
and insight not merely of the Emperor's
themselves and the personnel of the
court through which they exercised their
sway but also of the scholar officials
and cultivated gentry throughout the
provinces who sustained them and aspired
to refine and edify their judgment when
the denizens of that highly
differentiated and sometimes strongly
intellectually engaged media first took
up the challenge of attempting to
comprehend barbarian political practices
there I was firmly on power on the
peremptory need to turn the tables on
the ever more intrusive graceless and
disruptive traders and gunboats from the
West they sought to grasp where the
power which was relentlessly molesting
them had come from
and what it rested on in order to draw
on its sources directly for themselves
since the agencies which menaced them
had only the hazy accom prehension of
the answer themselves it was bound to
prove a lengthy and disconcerting quest
and even after the Chinese Communist
Party's triumphal assumption of power in
1949 it remains far from clear how much
real progress in ascertaining an answer
had been made in China until dung
shoppings decisive intervention and even
then the answer he hit upon was
explicitly pragmatic an agnostic over
issues of political economic or cultural
choice any style of cat provided it
catches the mice if you inspect the
current Battlefront in that very
long-running war of position the role of
democracy is very striking to American
observers all but inevitably it's a
category which challenges the political
standing of the Chinese Communist Party
and the legitimacy of all who've risen
to power through it it hovers
permanently on the brink of repudiating
Chinese sovereignty over Taiwan over
Tibet over Sinkiang and if the People's
Republic ever runs into big trouble and
regional wall or decree commences
potentially over any substantial segment
of the country from the viewpoint of
China's rulers it's a summons to
revolution to Anarchy or very least to a
dissipation or rupture of the power so
triumphantly accumulated in the earth
since 1979 two associates of the
incumbent government it's a category to
which they've already taken the
precaution of helping themselves whose
Republic after all is it if not the
people's deployed by their foreign
critics or by state enemies it indict
s-- them for fraud or wrongful
possession of what was never
for the Bears now that's clearly a
disagreement about very many things
it ranges far and wide it evokes
considerable animosity and it implicates
pressing interests on both sides there
perhaps clearer and less readily
admissible strictly personal stakes on
the Chinese side whose Republic is it
indeed at a minimum it's a disagreement
about how it's appropriate for a society
it required to acquire its leaders how
far those leaders should be subsequently
left unimpeded to act as they judge fit
what affects the degree of discretion
open to them in acting out their roles
are likely to have on the scruple or
self-restraint with which they choose to
do so and what effects the presence or
absence of external scrutiny and
personal accountability can be expected
to exert on the benign or Maleficent
impact that their governing on those at
the receiving end those are a lot of
issues to seek to organize through a
single and somewhat nebulous concept and
it's scarcely surprising that the
resulting disputes often prove dialogues
of the Deaf and virtually never much
clarify the viewpoints of either party
you can see that plurality of issues
either analytically or politically
viewed analytically it remains in
practically plural and any political
comprehension it contrives to provide is
necessarily provisional and hypothetical
a kaleidoscope which shifts its patterns
drastically every time you alter the
angle at which you choose to hold it and
seem politically it can of course be
every bit as plural an explicitly
relative to the position and engagements
of the individual or group who happens
to be looking at it but when it's viewed
politically it can also be summative a
judgment or choice
of all about where the weight of a
regimes political credibility does or
should rest and it's over that last
assessment but not nearly America's
leaders but most of its politically
interested population are so deeply at
odds
not just with China's current political
leaders but also as far as we can
currently ascertain with most of China's
politically interested population to
remember the anticipated response of
Iraq's population to being rescued by
shock-and-awe
the American conviction which now seems
to reach back uninterruptedly to 1776
comes above all from a process the
manner through which America's leaders
come by their authority there one
inspecting the United States today could
same ly conclude that it is governed by
its people but a handsome majority of
those who do in some sense govern it
today as throughout that impressive
timespan have obtained or retained the
opportunity to do so whether directly or
by delegation by courtesy of the people
that's not a claim which can plausibly
be defended for China at any point in
its vastly longer history across the
stark and sometimes violent
disagreements over what the people have
authorized or should authorize it to do
and however squalid confused and
misguided they believe that sequence of
choosing to have be Americans stand more
or less United in the proud conviction
that any authority their own government
has ever possessed to do anything has
come to it through the free choice of
the people from the confidence and
serenity of that viewpoint it's hard for
Americans through all their domestic
fears
humiliations crimes and sufferings not
to view the political predicaments of
most of the world with some degree of
calm
dissention nothing infuriates the people
of China across all their brutal
political and personal inequalities more
than barbarian condescension
hence the feebleness of the impulse
simply to accept as a unique and
decisive validation a criterion of
conspicuously barbarian provenance the
Chinese aren't going to be reconciled to
anything by news from pre Confucian
Mesopotamia a criterion which fetishizes
a process through which those who
currently rule China have plainly not
obtained their own opportunity to do so
evidently enough the implied relative
evaluation of the standing of the
respective states could hardly be
acceptable to China's current rulers but
it's just as important to recognize the
oddity through the prism of China's
vastly then through our political
experience of this entire way of
conceiving the relative strengths and
weaknesses of the two regimes it's not
as yet plausible at any rate to me to
suppose that China's experience may
somehow secrete within it a conception
of the responsibilities and character of
the modern state which is potentially
sounder and more powerful than the one
which eventually emerged from Europe's
largely self-inflicted political
torments but humans are very
intellectually inventive species and it
would be ill-advised as well as impolite
to rule the possibility out in advance
even if Chinese political construes are
unlikely in the short term to offer a
superior wholesale replacement for
American political understanding it's
far less evident that they may not
already present elements which might
help to balance the latter somewhat
better and refrain contemporary
judgments about what is or is not to be
done by whom
the world in a less unpromising fashion
the American critique of China's present
state always latent though mercifully
not always clearly audible in public or
I imagine even in private dialogue
between the two it's basically that
China's rulers have come by their
authority through a process which
couldn't stand inspection that it
provides no clear or reliable restraints
on how they deploy that authority leaves
them minimally and whimsically
accountable personally and wholly
unaccountable corporately to those over
whom they exercise it furnishes them
with no predictably potent or edifying
grounds to exert it with due
consideration for the interests of those
whom they rule fails with any
consistency to equip them with the
understanding or information required to
recognize what those interests really
are and therefore comprehensively fails
to protect their subjects China's
alleged citizens against the full impact
of those rulers indiscretion cynicism
greed or Stone enos of heart shade less
confidently quite a lot less plausibly
but also mercifully somewhat more muted
Li it goes on to suggest that those
incumbents have proved very poor
custodians of the interests of those
whom they rule and by implication far
worse custodians than their American
counterparts have contrived to prove
themselves in the altogether seem Lea
and better conceived political
architecture in which history has
privileged them to operate it's
important to think through to that last
point in the analytical sequence because
it brings out the orbit compulsive lack
of balance in America's perspective on
China and the consequent potential gain
of rebalancing American political
comprehension by what it's not
ludicrously overstrained to think of as
Chinese political comprehension
they're of courses in no sense a form of
comprehension exclusive to China until
that final point in the analytic
sequence by a necessity a moment of
summation there's no mistaking the force
of sorry there's no mistaking the force
of the American critique of China's
existing state indeed you can pick up
most elements in that critique sooner or
later in more sporadic and dispersed
fashion in the Chinese state's own
discourse with itself and its own
subjects a state of which all that's
true and much of it even apparent of the
state's own custodians and champions is
manifestly not a well-ordered state in
good political health very plausibly
it's an ill ordered state in a fairly
advanced degree of corruption and yet
it's that state which has changed China
more drastically than any previous state
has ever changed the life chances of
populations of distantly comparable size
that anything like that pace much
appalling harm has been perpetrated over
those three decades but there can hardly
be a sane person in the world who could
honorably will for China to turn the
clock back to 1979 how much better is
the United States in the round than it
was in 1979 so just whom is a clearly
better unbalanced democracy in the
American understanding is not a talisman
for ensuring satisfactory political
outcomes and it's both imprudent and
wrong to offer it to others as though it
were a balanced assessment of the
relative merits of two very different
societies political arrangements is a
precarious and taxing undertaking at the
best of times but as political
experience globalizes uncontrollably
it's going to have to be
taken more and more frequently and with
ever-growing urgency where the two
societies in question are already
incipient ly vying for world power and
each can only view itself as the
consummation of a long proud history or
jeopardize its sense of identity by
acknowledging irreparable hiatuses
within that history the intrinsic
difficulty of the comparison itself is
painfully exacerbated to recognize
China's formidable political strengths
is already to begin to impugn America's
political self-assurance a step which is
relatively effortless naturally but
China's rulers and which many have quite
audibly taken for China's current rulers
whatever they feel about one another
personally they are corporately the
source and basis of whatever order does
exist in and across China there is no
independent surviving source of order
and no external basis on which they or
anyone else could regularly set out to
construct one to choose to jeopardize
that already highly imperfect and
conspicuously vulnerable order would in
the classic phrase of Edmund Burke be to
play a most desperate game what could
give China's present rulers sufficient
reason to embark on that game more
pressingly what should give them such a
reason certainly not the imperative to
treat their own subjects better or
enhance their net welfare as effectively
as they can duties they in effect fully
acknowledge already in the beach if not
in the observance at least abstractly
and duties which they can only
coherently hope to address by focusing
and deepening the power of the state
they currently head when Chinese
officials first attempted to grasp what
American democracy was over a century
and a half ago they focused in turn on
three questions
what exactly was the apex of the
American state how did it get there and
what kept it there and what effects on
the ways it subsequently acted did the
way in which it got there really exert
it was the last of those three the
predictable effects of the mechanisms
for attaining political power which
first attracted serious Chinese
appreciation but it did so at a point
where there was no realistic possibility
of China adopting the same model in the
lengthy interval since then none of
those questions has lost interest and
all three have gained an apparent
significance from America's rise to
world power now as then the answers to
the first two questions exerted little
competitive pressure on Chinese visions
of the basis and value of China's order
I'll begin my first lecture next week by
sharing how rapidly the answer to that
third question how the ways in which
individuals come to rule affect the ways
in which they do rule began to press on
those visions and I'll try to set the
political configuration which emerge
from that comparison against the type of
political challenge that American
democracy now poses to the legitimacy of
China's state and the corresponding
solace which the American and the Indian
states each now draw from the common
element in their authorization